[Music]
hi and welcome to episode number 59 of
the weekly Google cloud platform podcast
i am francisco and i'm here with my
colleague mark Mandel hey Mark how are
you doing I'm good thanks Fran Cesc we
are a pot once again it's very sad yes
we are very very far apart last episode
I make you wake up really early this
time you're making me stay up late well
it's like 930 p.m. so yeah which is
about the time I'd normally be in bed so
it's pretty late so yeah marques lucky
to be in San Francisco while I'm
enjoying these ugly city no one has
heard about it's called Paris in France
yeah you know oh yeah that's the worst I
hate being embarrassed yeah and yeah
it's it's so weird it's like people
speak different I don't know I don't
ever like a butt but yeah we have a very
cool episode today yeah we have a return
guest yet again love it when our guests
come back Paul newson is returning to
speak to us about his sre rotation once
more he's now actually finished it yep
so he's coming to talk to us about being
a site reliability engineer yeah and it
is it is very interesting because even
though he has pretty much the same
messages as he had the beginning
basically saying you know I think that
this is the phase are the things that
are the most important now he's like oh
yeah those are definitely things that
had the most important he's gone through
through battle and now and and came back
with some lessons that he's gonna show
there so very good interview very
excited about it exactly the fire has
tempered the steel pre epic I like it
and and then after that we're gonna have
a question of the week related to App
Engine app engine and services that used
to be called modules and which one is
the default one and versions and stuff
like that cool all right well that's
great well before we go talk a two-pole
when we talk about our cool things of
the week I particularly like the first
one it has to do with one of my favorite
things communities yeah so it is a open
source project by the name of fishin a
service functions as a service for
Cabrini's so if you've become a fan
of like Croatoan Kurt service
programming or anything of that sort of
mantra this could be really cool because
it is an open source implementation of
being able to run functions on the cloud
but on an open source project like Ruben
a tease yeah it is pretty cool I'm
actually I'm gonna try it I saw that I
think the only languages that are
supported for by now our Python in
JavaScript yeah but I said by now
because I hope that that's gonna be
changing soon but I will definitely have
a look at it because it's it's a very
interesting thing of having like
basically the same idea of having cloud
functions but it is completely open
source so you can run it you can run it
on your premises or you can run it on ji
ke and you have full control whatever
things they're doing so that's that's
pretty great yeah the thing I kind of
excited by so you can respond to HTTP
requests which fair enough standard HTTP
stuff but the thing I quite like is it
will respond to khoobi near these events
mmm so as different stuff happens inside
your cluster you could respond like fire
up different things inside your cluster
it could be really interesting ways to
do things like custom auto scaling or
custom provisioning something that I'm
playing with a lot which so I think
that's quite cool that's a printer
esting thing and I I felt was the same
concern with everything there is related
to functions as service which is how are
people going to manage their source
codes I think that that's a very
interesting thing that not many people
have thought about it and very excited
but what is going to happen while we're
going to have spaghetti functions who
knows you know what we should do we
should reach out to the people behind
fission see if we get them on the
podcast that's a good idea that's a good
idea there you go well if you're
listening just reach out we would love
to have you yeah hello friends and then
we have the second part the second cool
thing of the week it's actually this
kind of fractal is a bunch of things
it's a series of blog posts and which
are completely on topic with today's
interviews interview because it's about
CRE which is not a sorry it's CRE which
is customer reliability engineering and
basically those are the people that are
sres for our customers
and they go through as you were saying
fire that temples the wood already poor
guy fire tempers the steel that there
you go so yeah they go through the to
the fire the tempered steel and then
they write about it so there's a bunch
of blog posts I had not seen them before
and those are some of the look blocked
wasn't gonna be reading while flying
around the world they look very
interesting and the cool thing is that
it is not like theoretical things are
things that actually happen and how to
solve them yeah I particularly I think
if you listen to this episode we talk a
lot about s ellos and SLA s which will
you'll hear about later and there's a
whole at this whole blog post about
those particular topics and why they're
important so if you want to learn more
about those particular things you're a
little light reading it's definitely a
place to go check out and i actually
just realized that we have one more cool
thing of the week which is actually
incredibly cool yes and it's not in the
show notes yet but a sr book is now free
yes definitely true so go with it it is
totally awesome I have two copies of it
one died bought another one that I got
for free and now maybe I will get
another one for free but it is
definitely worth it there's so much
stuff to learn from it yes yes you
should definitely do that and we will
definitely have a link to that in the
show notes yeah absolutely okay cool so
I think it's now time to go talk to Paul
yeah our colleague and it's an honor
he's the first essary advocate ever he
coming to term and he said it was coined
in 2016 so you know it's been a long
time since then yeah s every advocate
2016 fullness that's where came from
good talk to him then led to that so
very happy to welcome our dear friend
Paul Newson back to the podcast for the
third time owning the record of number
of appearances in the part in this
podcast other than for Mark and I so
Paul Newson how are you doing I'm doing
great today how are you guys doing great
very happy to have you back after i was
i was looking at it we had a in February
24 2016 so
almost a year ago we had you for storage
with pollution and then 14 x 2 + 10 yes
38 we had you to talk about site
reliability engineering and and that was
almost six months ago and you've been
learning a lot about site reliability
engineering since then so we were very
happy to have you back to talk about
that yeah I think at the end of the
previous podcast I made a suggestion
that hey maybe after I've done with my
mission control rotation I can come back
and maybe share a few more insights
hopefully no more about what I'm talking
about then I did the first time around
we're not only been doing it for a few
weeks before we get stuck into that I
mean for people who don't know who you
are do you want to give us a little
spiel about you ya doin officer people
that didn't know I'm sure most people
though yes oh yeah yeah I'm that
internet famous I'm sure no I don't
expect anyone to know who I am unless of
course you listen to the previous
episode of the podcast and if you did
that was months ago so why would you you
know remember that far back but I am a
developer advocate at Google I work on
the cloud developer relations team with
mark and France esque but for the past
eight months I did a very interesting
rotation where I embedded myself with
one of our site reliability engineering
teams specifically the site reliability
engineering team that looks after
compute engine and the idea was to
hopefully learn enough about site
reliability engineering that I could go
out as a developer advocate and and talk
about it and because telling the story
of how we manage our services and by
extension if you're using our cloud
platform how we manage the
infrastructure that you're using there's
a very interesting story to tell and
it's it's something that I hope I can I
can share with people and give them some
confidence that you want to run your
stuff on our stuff that was the idea at
the beginning and i would say that I've
certainly learned
lot of things that I want to tell people
about and hopefully we can touch on some
of those today but what's what's
interesting is that the the sre culture
that I just embedded myself into for
eight months has a lot of insights that
are useful to more than just Google this
isn't something that is Google specific
or Google only there are other people in
our industry who are doing great work
that's very similar to what we do here
at Google and there are very real
lessons that you can apply to your
services running on our services from
how we do site reliability engineering
at Google so now I'm very excited to go
out to share some of those things with
the broader community cool i'm so very
quick recap as well for people who
unfortunately didn't listen to the
previous episode what is site
reliability engineering what is an SRA
so site reliability engineering is what
google calls the operations function and
to once again quote been trainer like i
did last time it's what happens when you
put a software engineer in charge of
your operations function and so what you
end up with is a culture of automation
and a culture of using software to make
the operations problem better or easier
or faster and as I touched on in the
last episode you know there are some
really important insights to this
because when you operate at very high
scale if you try and scale the number of
people taking care of your stuff with
the amount of stuff that you have it it
quickly becomes an out-of-control
problem so instead what you do is you
hire people who are really good at
automating things and yes you do some
manual work along the way but your
primary job the thing you spend more
than half of your time on is automating
that toil as we call it away and that's
so those are sort of the two halves of
site reliability engineering there's a
certain amount of keeping Google up
responding to incidents
being on call and then the majority of
the job is building software to make the
services easier to run so that is you
double your customers and double again
and double again and you add more
features and add more features and you
increase the surface area of this
product you don't also have to double
the size of your operations teams again
and again and again because that just
becomes impossible to do so it's got
like that thing of go away or I will
replace you with a simple shell script
but to yourself yes exactly you want to
automate yourself out of a job as
quickly as possible so you can go on to
something newer and interesting you know
we a common characteristic of many site
reliability engineers at Google is they
get bored very easy so you know you do
something once you do it twice and then
you write a script you know it's a very
very common thing in our industry it's
not unique to Google at all but we do
try to you know live up to that to that
sort of that way of doing things because
for us it's not just a case of well I
don't want to do it a third time it's a
case of by the time you have to do it a
third time you've got these other things
that are piling up as well so you want
to automate these things as quickly as
you can otherwise pretty soon you won't
be able to keep up with it you just
won't be able to do it manually anymore
so yeah so that that is very interesting
we covered that in the previous episode
episode 38 38 34 38 yeah 38 I feel like
I'm repeating myself for a lot of this
no but it is very interesting and and I
I guess that if people are interested on
on what is the whole philosophy behind
sre they should just go listen to that
episode yeah this is sre the sequel yeah
this is the sequel so so I guess that
you've been an SRE for a bunch of months
six months eight months yeah I was eight
months and I'm still you know wrapping
up a couple of projects for the SAS
every team I was on so it you know by
the time I'm done it will have been nine
ten months of sre work which is you know
I'm pretty happy with that it was a good
body of work it was enough
time for me to really hopefully make a
positive impact on the team that hosted
me and not just you know suck knowledge
out of their heads and but also to be
able to internalize and really walk in
their shoes for long enough to be able
to represent their worldview to the
Internet out there today yeah cool so
when we first had you on you'd been on I
think for about a month now obviously
you've been there for eight what did you
feel was like sort of how did the end
differ from the beginning how do you
feel like your impression has changed
since that time period of being an SRA
so uh I actually went back and relisted
to the previous podcast this morning in
the hopes that I wouldn't repeat myself
well that's exactly what i just did
because those thoughts were in my head
but hopefully they're still interesting
to this audience but as I you know I
made some I made some statements at that
time about you know you know I'm just
new at this and i'm mostly repeating
what I've heard and honestly a lot of
the things I I said in that in that
previous podcast they stand up today
quite well so if you go back and listen
to that not only do I think they still
are quite applicable and quite accurate
but I received feedback from some fairly
senior Google sres who listen to this
podcast and and they were quite positive
they said hey you really you really did
a good job of representing what we do
and we find we're often misunderstood
not just in the industry but even within
Google you know as as what is the
difference between development teams sre
teams and what is traditionally thought
of his operations so however i'd say the
big difference between you know what I
what I had experienced at that time and
what I've experienced now is since then
I got trained up enough so that I
actually went on call and carried the
pager so I was the first responder for a
piece of Google compute engine for
several weeks since ice
to you guys last and that that was a
very interesting experience I ever
called that like yeah I would panic
probably interesting terrifying
interesting is a nice way of putting it
yeah it's it's an interesting experience
and it can be terrifying i gotta say
like the first time that I saw my name
listed on the on the page that shows
who's on call that was that was a little
bit surreal and now to be fair I've been
on call before I worked on the cloud
storage product before i joined
developer relations that product i was
on call for that product at the time but
I helped build it so I really felt like
well throw whatever you want it be I
know how this thing works from beginning
to end i can i can probably troubleshoot
what's going on this was a very
different experience for me and is more
typical of the sra experience where you
are given something that somebody else
has built and yes you become very
familiar with it over time but i can't
possibly know it as well as the people
who built it right so I've gone from
being on call for something that I built
to being on call for something I didn't
and that was you know a little a little
bit terrifying but what what was very
reassuring was you're not out there
alone it's not like you know here's the
pager good luck we'll see you in a week
there's an entire team yes you are the
first responder but there is an entire
team there to back you up and mostly
what you need to do is apply good
judgment on when to escalate and when to
bring other people in and also know you
know what are those paths to do that so
I was I was primary oncall when we had
what is called an incident which is
something that's significant enough that
you need to bring other people into it
you can't just you know fix it quickly
yourself and so I had the experience of
going through the entire incident
management process and it really begins
a lot earlier that when you go on call
you you know you do a lot of training
you learn about your product you
projects in your project you shadow
other people you are secondary and then
eventually you become primary and you
are on on point and but when you when
you declare an incident at Google there
is a there's a tool that we use that to
sort of track the state and the status
and show where you know how are you
communicating about it where do people
go if they want to participate in the
response and even though and at no point
during the incident was I the one fixing
the problem it was all about making sure
that people who could fix the problem
were on the case and and doing the right
things and then when the when the
incident was mitigated and and service
was back at a hundred percent at that
point you start a post-mortem and this
is something I I talked just a little
bit about in the previous interview but
I now know much more deeply having gone
through it these post-mortems are
incredibly useful things google has what
we call a blameless post mortem culture
so the the idea behind writing a post
mortem is not to figure out who made a
mistake and then to punish the guilty
it's actually the opposite of that you
assume that we believe that the people
who were involved in the incident
response the people who are on call at
the time are qualified to be there
they've been trained as well as we can
they are well-meaning and
well-intentioned and when things go
wrong it's not because people should
have done better it's because the
environment around them the tools the
processes the the monitoring the
alerting these things were somehow could
be better and if you want to avoid this
problem in the future you need to change
these tools the processes or change the
product so this particular type of
problem can never occur again and that's
what the post-mortem is supposed to
bring out and so you write the post
mortem everybody you know adds their
thoughts to it
you file a bunch of follow-up items so
that these things because a document
that nobody reads and nobody acts on is
no good to anyone these things are filed
and tracked you know the same as any
other product issue and then and then at
some point you have what we call
incident review meeting where a group of
people who work on that product and the
people who were involved in the
particular incident will get down in
review no get into a room and and review
the post-mortem and this is also a very
interesting experience because it does a
couple of things one it helps improve
the postmortem because you have people
there who weren't directly involved but
who are very experienced and bring a
fresh perspective and they might think
of additional things that you didn't
think of that we can follow up on to
make make the product better but the
second thing it does is it socializes
this particular incident among the
responders the people who might respond
to have to respond to things in the
future and it builds this culture around
we understand from we learn from these
problems we have in the past to make
things better and and and these these
review beings are an important part of
that so I think the the question was
originally what's different now from the
beginning and I'd say the the most
significant difference between you know
the what I knew then and what I know now
it comes from living through being on
call and handling incidents at Google so
that sounds like it's it's very
interesting and and for those that do
not have the privilege of being able to
do with what you did in becoming a
necessary for almost a year I guess that
there's many resources out there I think
that one of my favorite ones is the sre
book yes I guess you would recommend
that book i would i would highly
recommend that book in fact I've I've i
sat next to what I went through my
orientation we had some some senior sres
who'd been at the company doing the
essay a role for years come and have
lunch with us and one of them said yeah
everybody everybody who's in sr we
should read this book i learned things
from this book this is somebody who's
been doing
at Google what because because the way
this book was put together was it was it
was sort of crowd-sourced within the sre
organization so what what you really
have when you when you have that book is
the is a collection of authoritative
essays written by the person at Google
who knows that subject the best right so
you know there's for example there's a
chapter on post-mortems which I just
discussed in the chapter on incident
response which I just discussed and they
were written probably by different
people and probably by the people who
were best positioned to really write the
authoritative treatment of that subject
well no you know nobody at Google is
going to be as knowledgeable about all
of the subjects covered by that book as
the individual authors of each chapter
so long time s Ariz at Google get
benefit from reading that book so yes I
do highly highly recommend it so for
those that are lazy too lazy to read
that book like me I actually have read
the book anything is amazing but for
those that do not have the time to read
the book if you were to highlight one
specific fame or one concept that is
very very important for a nursery
something that you might have discovered
during this year what could it be so I
think the the most surprising and I
won't say it surprised me because it was
a concept i was really aware of from my
previous work on cloud storage but the
importance of having really well thought
out service level objectives the
surprise isn't that that's important the
surprise to me was how central that is
to everything you need to do to think
about reliability so what is a service
level objective so a service level
objective is let me back up a second a
service level indicator is something you
can measure about your service so let's
say for example let's just take a simple
request response sort of HTTP service a
very simple service level indicator is
what percentage of my responses are 500
class so error rate and you know that's
a very relevant metric that you should
probably be tracking and have on a graph
and maybe even alert on but what turns a
service level indicator into a service
level objective is sitting down and
asking yourself well for this for this
indicator what is the threshold like
what is our goal what are we trying to
reach here so for example if it's if
we're talking about error rate maybe you
want to be three nines you know so you
you are going to give yourself you're
going to give yourself a goal of 999
times out of a thousand you are going to
serve you know a non 500 response maybe
that's the goal of your service and
maybe that's appropriate for your
service but you have to think about it
from the customer's point of view like
what's sort of what is that transaction
what is that HTTP request you've been
given is your service something where
all these HTTP requests are item potent
and can be easily repeated with
exponential back-off 39 s is probably
very sufficient for something like that
because what's the client going to do
what's the user going to do well the
client software is probably going to
retry automatically for them and the
user will never notice that a 500 was
served so what transforms an SLI into an
SLO is this user insight that you have
to bring and say for this indicator what
is an acceptable threshold beyond which
we shouldn't go now a lot of people
would call that an SLA service level
agreement and at Google we try very hard
to to be clear about what is an SLI
service level indicator it's just
something we measure you know there's a
graph somewhere that you can go look at
that the tracks whatever that metric is
a service level objective is an SLI with
a with a threshold of some kind applied
to it some sort of goal an SLA is a
legal contract between two companies
that are doing business together and
they kind of look like s ellos sometimes
but really the SLA is the contract you
can have lots of services that have s
ellos with no SLA whatsoever like I did
a I collaborated with Philippe our
colleague on a post about github
reliability a few months back and you
know github is a service if you're just
using the free service they have no SLA
it would make sense to have a service
level agreement you're not paying them
any money how can they give you a credit
are they going to do like write you a
check because they gave you a 500 you
know it doesn't make thing it doesn't it
doesn't make sense but I'm I'm quite
sure that internally at github they have
objectives for how many errors they want
to serve they have SLO s even though
they don't have a public-facing SLA so
the SLO is the thing that drives your
decision-making around almost everything
you do with your service and I'd say
that is what I found the most surprising
that is the most valuable insight that
I've come away with from from this
rotation you know let's say for example
you're trying to figure out how many
regions do I need to run in and and so
you can analyze your architectures and
say well if I run in one region multiple
zones in one region I can expect this
sort of reliability if I run in multiple
regions I can expect more reliability
because I'm now more redundant across
more geographies should i do it it's
more expensive it's more engineering
work if your SLO demands that you need
that redundancy then yes you should do
it if your SLO doesn't demand that you
need that redundancy then you shouldn't
do it because you're just wasting money
you should you if your SLO is well
chosen your customers will not notice
the difference between meeting it and
exceeding it greatly there's no extra
value to exceeding your SLO greatly if
you've chosen it well an example would
be that most most people connect to
internet services through networks that
only provide three or four
signs to them so while you could provide
five nines for your your website that
additional reliability is pretty much
imperceptible to your customers you are
spending a lot of effort and money
providing a higher level of reliability
that provides no value to your customers
now there are of course services where
this doesn't apply right anything that
is life safety critical anything where
each each request may have like failing
a request has an actual cost each time
you know they may require a different
calculus on how to how to think about
your SLO but that's a that's a very
that's something that no one can decide
for you right you understanding your
users and having empathy for them and
thinking about your product only you can
choose your SLO but once you do that can
help guide architectural decisions
operational decisions deployment
decisions technology decisions and so on
and so on yeah I I think we've had very
interesting discussions about having SLO
s drive like feature development in
terms of like how much work should be
put in on this thing because changes are
essentially risk right yeah so the other
thing that's that's a very very good
point I think I made the point in the
previous interview that if you want to
have a service that is a hundred percent
reliable that's easy never change
anything the I exaggerate of course even
then you would you know depending on
your service you still wouldn't have a
hundred percent but the point is every
change you make to your service carry
some risk with it but how do you decide
if that risk is worth it you know this
is a fantastic feature we absolutely
have to ship it we have to ship it
tomorrow how do you how do you think
about the risk of shipping that feature
well have you met your SLO this month do
you have some error budget left over you
know we talked about SLO and error
budget there's sort of two sides of the
same coin if you have say a ninety-nine
point nine percent SLO that means you
have a point one percent error budget
if you haven't served any errors this
month yeah it's risky to push this new
version but if something bad happens
well you'll just eat into your error
budget that's what it's there for on the
other hand if you've had problems this
month and you've already exhausted your
error budget you know give your users a
break and wait until you've had some
periods of high reliability and you've
replenished your error budget before you
push that change it also reflects on
things like well how do you push your
changes one of the great recipes for how
to have a wonderful global outage a
wonderful global extended outage is to
push a change everywhere all at once and
have no rollback plan that's a great
recipe for an extended global outage to
your service instead if you do your
rollouts progressively so you push it
you know a little bit over here wait
monitor see if anything goes wrong push
a little bit more weight monitor see if
anything goes wrong and so on and so on
you can do this over a period of hours
over a period of days over a period of
weeks even depending on what your
service you know what SLO are you trying
to make what is the right pace to push
out your changes that depends on your
SLO this is how like all of these
questions like I can't tell you whether
minutes days or weeks is the right pace
for your rollout you can only answer
that based on what SLO you're going for
and that will guide you in the decision
to what kind of roll out and what pace
of roll out you need to do and then
again you know do I absolutely need to
have a rollback plan for this well the
the now sre that lives on my shoulder
says of course you need a rollback plan
that's like that's the most important
thing you could have a rollout but
looking at it objectively if you have a
very low SLO and you can basically
repose your entire service in a couple
of hours and a couple of our outage is
well within your SLO then I guess you
could push without a rollback plan but
one of the best ways to improve your
reliability is not to never break
anything but to make sure you can always
fix it
quickly right because outages that are
measured in in minutes are not as
painful as outages that are measured in
hours or heaven forbid days so having
you know great well tested rollback
plans and rollback tools such that yeah
sure I'm pushing this thing and I pushed
it here and then I waited 24 hours and I
pushed it here again I waited another 24
hours and then I saw something was wrong
well now I can roll back and not that
many people were affected to begin with
and we were able to mitigate it really
quickly cool well we're we're definitely
coming up on time so as much as we could
we could talk about this for hours on
end before we finish up is there
anything we haven't covered or maybe
like what your next up to what do you
what are you doing except for this
rotation so let's see um if you like
what I have to say about this topic and
you didn't find a half an hour of me you
know rambling on about it to be enough
I'm I'm hoping to put together a talk
for for next so come to the conference
come see my talk and I also hope to
basically take this message on the road
and get out to other events and and talk
about these things the other thing that
I'm hoping to do I I had a goal I think
I spoke about it in the first podcast to
almost write a diary of my mission
control rotation I thought it would be
really cool if people could sort of play
along with me as I went through hmm
turns out being a big and necessary can
be rather all-consuming so my my series
of blog Bose posts turned into two blog
posts but I have another one on the way
and I'm hoping to continue to do more
because these insights are pretty
timeless so keep an eye on the gcp on
the Google cloud platform blog and
hopefully you'll you'll see some things
from me there on this topic and the
other thing I'd like to I'm hoping to to
do is
you know I've now I now feel like I have
a very good understanding of how Google
approaches this one of the one of my my
hopes for going out into the community
and going to these conferences and
talking about this is not just to stand
there and say hey this is how Google
does it you should do it this way too
but I want to learn a lot more about
well how do people who aren't Google do
this like there's a broader community
out there doing things that they call
ops or DevOps or sometimes heh sorry and
I want to understand what does this look
like if you're not Google because I
believe that'll be really important for
us to guide our guide our customers to
do the right things like some some of
the things that we do at the scale we
operate at may not apply some of them
may to our customers the other thing
I'll do is just give a you know give a
quick mention of this program we have
now called customer reliability
engineering this is essentially sres who
work directly with with customers it's a
very small program it's just getting
started we wrote a blog post on it I
won't say any more about it because I'm
not an expert on it but I just want to
make you aware that it exists you should
go read the blog post and if you're
curious about it there's probably some
contacts in there you can follow up with
excellent great well looking forward to
seeing your talk cloud next just in case
people are wondering that will be in San
Francisco March 8th to 10th so see you
there and thank you again for taking the
time to tell us about your experience
and looking forward to reading all of
those blog posts that I hope you're
going to be writing soon thanks guys
thanks again to our always reliable
colleague Paul newson for joining us we
had a splendid conversation about being
an SRE and all the things involved super
super interesting stuff and like yeah
that s our ebook is free so like there
is no excuse not to go read it yeah it's
definitely worth the read it's it's
actually very well written it's like it
basically instead of a really big book
with just one message is a bunch of
little stories of how we do things at
Google
so it's easy to read you can read any of
the sections that you care about so
definitely worth reading especially for
the price which is free right now so
yeah awesome alright so let's get stuck
into the question of the week let's do
so we're talking about App Engine so if
you're using App Engine and so App
Engine allows you to have multiple
versions of an appt up in the cloud and
running which is really really useful
but if I'm using App Engine and I want
to see which version of my service that
I have up and running the cloud which
ones default which is the one that
everyone is seeing when they access like
my usual URL France s can you help me
out yeah so there's a couple things of a
big question so first I think the
important thing is to understand that
inside of a single app engine
application you can have actually many
services which is what we used to call
modules oh yeah and and at which are the
same thing that we just change the name
basically and every single one of those
modules can be written in a completely
different language so you know can be
cool you can have some some Python and
then some go and something raining yeah
we do that on the podcast actually do we
do it absolutely because we have one
modern go when one model which is static
content so they're they're independent
and then instead of each one of those
modules we can have many versions and
that is very useful especially when
you're doing a be testing or just
testing basically if you want to have
something tested on improv which is you
know not a great idea but we all do it
so you're going to deploy it and then
make sure it actually works before you
send all your customers to that new web
page or that new service so before we
actually have that concept of the
default version meaning that if you did
not specify which version you were going
to target then you could target that
default version in that thing actually
went away there's no such thing as
default version instead what we have is
we have traffic splitting which means
that you could do something like actual
a be testing saying you know I'm going
to have fifty percent of the traffic
going to version a then 25 going to
version B and another 25 going to
version see
so I could also like smoke tests new
features like ten percent of the traffic
gets a new feature get test it out make
sure it works and if it does I can just
increase the traffic that it receives
absolutely you can do you can do a be
testing you can do like experiments and
seems like only one percent of the
people hitting the web page is going to
see this new feature and you see if they
like it or not nice ah so which that
means basically that you cannot check
which one is the default sir the default
version of a service instead what you
can do is you can list all the services
in sorry all the versions in a surface
and when you do that which there's a
recipe I call apps that service / get so
you do a REST API there and you get a
list of all the versions running in the
service and which is the traffic split
that they got so the equivalent of
default would be one which is one
hundred percent of the traffic but you
could get like as we saying zero the 50
25 or whatever else you want so it's not
quite as clean as I don't understand so
it's not quite as simple as the default
quote option used to be but is much more
flexible in terms of what you can
actually do yeah basically it is you can
still implement that default version
saying one hundred percent traffic goes
there but you can do much more which is
actually very good that sounds good I
like it excellent alright francisc I
know you're still out and about and
having fun in Europe where are you going
to be over the next little while so I'm
going to go to Brussels next for fuss
them where I'm going to be joining two
of our co-workers I'm going to be
joining Philippa alpha which we
interviewed long time ago about Big Data
mb query and also I will meet with ray
which we interviewed last week about
Java so we'll all get the three of us
there so if you're around come say hi
and after that I'll be coming back to
San Francisco for just a little bit
basically do laundry and then go to go
for Cornelia nice yeah very excitable
India excellent about the right still
doing same old same old very busy
getting things ready GDC is turning out
to be huge game developer game developer
conference
in San Francisco we're sponsoring
multiple events it looks like we're
going to have a booth which is great the
last minute but fun fun fun so we
running things at the booth I'll be sure
to tell everyone's going on there
shortly sponsored session i'm doing a
lightning talk at the developer day lots
going on so i'm getting that already and
then yeah cloud next comes the week
after which will be fun fun fun as well
I know you and I are both speaking yes
that's going to be a delightful time and
I believe we also have space for the
podcast so if you want to come and hang
out and maybe get a recording in that we
may or may not use later definitely
swing past and say hello at the podcast
absolutely well Fran Cesc it was a
pleasure and delight to talk to you once
again missing you here in San Francisco
but it'll be nice to have you back here
soon same here pleasure and i'll be back
to san francisco very person and so see
you soon and thanks everyone for
listening and talk to you all next week
see you all next week
you
[Music]